si africains et européens on n'est pas
les mêmes mais on peut partager
certaines valeurs on est différent mais
vous pouvez être ensemble moi c'est ça
il faut que nous acceptions les
différences mais que nous allions
ensemble vers ce que nous voulons bâtir
a commencé comme ça que je vois en tout
cas la plateforme qui pourra nous
permettre de combattre ensemble tous
ceux qui sont contre ces valeurs
communes que nous pouvons développer et
qui se nourrissent de la haine et du
discours qui veut créer un discours
hégémonique pour justifier justement
leur forfait en utilisant la religion
est l'islam dès la première victime
ce que vous ne trouvez déjà en train de
prier dans une mosquée vous mettez une
bombe pour les tuer on ne peut pas
appeler ça de l'islam ou venez dans une
église tuer des fidèles catholiques
alors que le prophète mohammed
pendant qu'il était à médine a hébergé
dans sa mosquée des gens qui étaient
inquiètes de zones de prière pour pas
dire que l'islam est l'islam que nous
connaissons nouveau sénégal qui est un
islam de tolérance que nous assumons ne
peut pas aller dans cette direction mais
nous voulons aussi qu'il y ait de la
tolérance vis-à-vis de l'islam tolérante
bien combattre le terrorisme nous sommes
ensemble au mali nous sommes ensemble
donc beaucoup de théâtre il faut que
nous nous battions ensemble compte ces
extrêmes maison mais il faut aussi qu'on
respecte la défense pour juste pouvoir
parler avec les autres communautés que
tout le monde n'est pas au même niveau
de compréhension tout le monde
voilà n'a pas la même compréhension des
phénomènes des sujets ainsi va le mans